foreign
[Music]
we'll start with this so my boyfriend
and I both work the day shift so we're
both home after 6 PM we have our days
off set up okay first of all she started
a sentence with the word so so she's
already an a-hole
it's another thing I hate
I'm in a really bad mood right now I've
realized
so I'm just everyone's in a-hole this
time we have our days off set up that uh
he is off Saturdays and Sundays and I'm
off Sundays and Mondays we each get one
day off to ourselves to just be alone
and do our thing and then one day off
together to do whatever we want as well
my boyfriend and I have fairly different
Hobbies he's really into fitness and
working out and always being active I'm
a pretty strong gamer and I don't care
about any of this who cares what is your
complaint lady so he stayed up stupid
late last night and called into work
this morning nine times out of ten I
wouldn't care but it's Monday it's my
only day to myself and he's constantly
bugging me to go to work out with him or
go on a hike or generally to just be
active because he's bored oh God forbid
he's trying to help you help you be a
fit and healthy person he doesn't want
you to to die of heart disease God
forbid yeah my boyfriend is so annoying
he wants me to do things like stand up
my boyfriend wants me to walk outside
encounter the Sun every every once in a
while again nine times out of ten
wouldn't matter and I'd spend a few days
doing whatever he wanted I need this day
to just be quiet and dark and Me time
I'm 100 on the opposite end of a social
person I just want my one day to be
alone to recuperate for the week I look
forward to this one day the entire week
I'm definitely annoyed and definitely
showing it even though I'm trying not to
I've tried explaining this I've tried
being nice and just telling him that I
need some me time and he's just not
listening I pretty much snapped and told
him to just leave me the F alone for a
bit and now he's sulking in the living
room
am I the a-hole okay and then there's
even more information that we don't need
so you got into a fight with your
boyfriend and he sulked off and you
immediately went on your phone to Reddit
now Reddit says that this woman is not
the a-hole and Reddit is wrong this time
and not for the first time you're
definitely the a-hole for a few reasons
first of all why are you playing house
why are you playing marriage you know by
living together if you don't even want
to be around each other so you can't
stand to be around the guy for more than
one day of the week but you're living
with him this is not working out okay
you guys need to break up just break up
take my vote go live on your own or do
you don't want to live on your own
because you don't have to pay for it
right that's that's probably it so you
want the boyfriend there to help you pay
for the rent or maybe pay all the rent I
don't know but you don't want to
actually be around him what you're
looking for is welfare okay go live on
your own and get on welfare don't give
me this oh I need I need space I need me
time I need I need to relax I need to
you're just dating someone you have no
kids
you know you work a nine to five job you
have off on the weekends and you're
complaining about how you need space and
time and I really need my break for what
like you live some kind of stressful
life this is the only workout that many
people get is just complaining about how
stuff's so stressed in my life I cannot
even conceive of having an existence as
easy as you and you're still whining is
there anyone who's not an a-hole
I think I'm just the a-hole this time
[Music]
the a-hole for not wanting the clock in
the car to be five minutes fast my wife
has always kept the clock in her car
five minutes fast ahead of the actual
time I tried this technique in the past
but found it would work for me we each
have our own car along with a shared
carb that the whole family uses it was
driving me nuts nuts that I'd look at
the clock remember it's not right then I
have to check my watch to see the actual
time and then it goes on for another 50
paragraphs but that's basically the
thing should they have the clock set
ahead in their car uh no you're not the
a-hole for not wanting the clock set
ahead the setting the clock's ahead
thing is absurd because when you do that
you just end up doing the math in your
head anyway so I don't understand the
strategy you're not actually fooling
yourself into thinking the time is
different than it actually is so you're
giving yourself a math assignment every
time you get in the car uh so no you're
not the a-hole for that
[Music]
foreign
had a baby seven months ago my parents
came to us for Thanksgiving dinner this
year my wife made a great spread as we
were about to eat the baby started
fussing he has been teething I told my
wife she should go attend to him but she
asked if I could because she hadn't
eaten all day because she was trying to
care for the baby cook everything and
try to visit with my parents and she
would really like a warm meal instead
and it had been a while since she'd had
one I said it would be really rude to my
parents to sit down without me since in
my family the hosting family member was
always at the table with the guests my
wife asked me again to please go but I
was annoyed and said no I could tell my
wife was irritated but she went to our
baby I was thinking we'd wait for her to
return but my dad said he was starving
and everything looked fantastic
so I told them to dig in my wife seemed
to be having a hard time getting our son
to settle down but she's always had the
Magic Touch when it comes to him so I
left her to it
that was very nice of you by the time he
was content and quiet again we'd
finished and we had moved into the other
room
I had left everything on the table and
when I went back around she was feeding
the baby I said she should probably
clean up once she was done and she
really coldly asked when exactly she was
supposed to eat I was taken by surprise
and asked what she was on about and she
told me that she hadn't eaten anything
and I had left a mess instead of at
least taking the used dishes to the sink
and she she knew it was too much to
think I'd actually be bothered to make
her a plate too I got irritated and told
her that she was being dramatic
we were that we were hosting and I
thought it was more important to spend
time with my parents she said that I was
the one who invited my parents over but
I left her to do everything I said that
wasn't true but she asked me to name
just one thing I'd done to help her I
was put on the spot and I couldn't think
of something so she said exactly I got
pretty angry but my mom came in then and
asked if she could feed the baby my God
are you still talking my wife said yes
then started making herself a plate so
she could eat my mom was upset with me
when she realized that my wife still had
need okay first of all
before your wife ate
did you make sure that she had cleaned
the bathroom because it's not it's not
fair to leave a messy bathroom when
their guests over no I you know I I'm
actually concerned that um as a as a
five-year-old you're probably way too
young to be married I mean I believe in
early marriage but that's too far I
think even for me I can only assume that
you're five and have been married for
five minutes based on your behavior as
you describe it you know you know what
you are actually you you you're like
Kevin James or Ray Romano from a 90s
like a 90s sitcom you know you did
literally everything wrong every step of
the way he's an you're so wrong
and outlandishly polish that I'm not
sure if I even believe that this is real
but then the whole bit breaks down if
it's not real so we'll just charge ahead
and pretend that it is
I'm the winner
[Music]